I don't know what world we can ever live
in where we say that Trump is less
divisive for the country than Biden I
think it is so patently obvious Trump is
so divisive like not only does Trump
make an enemy out of every person in the
opposition party he makes an enemy out
of his own party and every single person
around him like we all watched him bully
uh you know Jeff sessions we all watched
him bully his own party on Twitter we
all watched like all of these people
walk away from him um even recently I
think um his uh the Secretary of Defense
esper and um John Kelly the chief of
staff were you know saying I think Trump
is a threat to democracy um you know
you've got all of his prior people that
were around him some of his closest
allies you've got Bill bar that won't
co-sign a single thing that he says um
you've got all these people that he used
to work with that all say Trump is a
horrible evil person he is ineffective
as a leader he doesn't accomplish
anything and he didn't you know to say
that Biden has failed at bipartisanship
when you know we've gotten the chips act
we've gotten the IRA we've gotten the
ARP we've gotten the bipartisan
infrastructure bill when we've got like
all this major legislation that is
working in this historically divided
Congress as opposed to Trump that got us
tax cuts and deficit spending um I I I
don't understand where we ever are in
this world where Biden is somehow more
divisive than Trump even the speeches
that Ben is bringing up I they they
always bring up I remember that one um I
think we might have even done it on our
episode though the one speech that Biden
gave were at one point that like the
background is red and spe reference yeah
they're like oh my God it's over this is
the end and then meanwhile you got
Donald Trump you know coming into office
saying things like if you burn the flag
you should have your citizenship revoked
or talking about Ms DNC that I'm going
to investigate every single one of these
uh media organizations for corruptness
I'm going to open the Lial and
defamation laws and I'm going to take
all of these guys to court um you've got
this weird project 2025 stuff where um
is it John pasel I think uh is talking
about uh you know we're gonna we're
gonna investigate all of these people
and we're going to try to throw crimes
at all these people uh Trump is like the
most divisive president I think we've
ever had in in at least in my lifetime
of being um an American citizen and the
rhetoric from him is just it's on a
whole other level in terms of the
demonization of political opponents I
mean this is a guy that's known for
giving his political opponents bad
nicknames right like that's what Trump
does um you know like it's funny but
even as a resident of Florida if Florida
had another natural disaster do you
think Trump would withhold Aid because
you had uh I think that was one of the
few nice things that Des Sanz actually
said about Biden was like Hey listen you
know when the buildings collapsed in I
think that was Miami Beach yeah that um
you know for the hurricane stuff that
Biden was there he was saying if you
guys need Aid however many billions you
can have it meanwhile Trump I think was
threatening to withhold Federal funding
from Blue states that wouldn't um I
think it had to do with the National
Guard stuff the deployment of the
National Guard that they weren't like
doing enough for the riots and and uh
Trump was threatening to withhold aid
from some of these blue States um yeah
Trump is literally the most divisive
person in the world I don't see how on
any metric he has ever succeeded in the
divisive category in terms of the
economy I do think it's fny that
Republicans are very keen to say that
like well we can't really grade Trump
you know postco because obviously Co
messed everything up which is fair but
preo what did Trump do yeah he did he
did deficit spending tax cuts he
presided over historic low interest
rates and an economy that was already
like like blazing past the final years
of Obama we were posting all-time highs
in all the stock markets in 2013 onwards
um you know unemployment rates were
falling now under Biden unemployment
rates are even lower than they were
under Trump but uh it it sucks that for
Trump we can say well we can't really
hold him accountable for 2020 that was
Co well all we have for Biden is postco
we don't have any pre-co Biden uh you
know economy and it was the same thing
for Obama too coming in right after the
housing collapse as well and it sucks
that Republicans are able to walk out of
office you know having burned the entire
American society to the ground
economically and now we've got to try to
evaluate okay well what did Obama do
during his first two to three to four
years just trying to recover from where
the housing crash left it and then we
look at Biden now who's trying to
recover from covid and now we're grading
him on on a totally different scale than
what Trump is being graded on yeah that
that sucks I think comment on the
foreign policy on the foreign policy I'm
going to be honest I am a um I am very
liberal I'm very not Progressive uh I'll
probably come off as more hawkish than
others uh because I'm not a big fan of
this which also if I mean if then agrees
like I think uh people like people like
Trump are going to be the most dovish
isolationist people ever they don't want
to do anything uh internationally they
just want to you know Protect America be
at home protect our economy don't do
anything uh internationally which is why
he was constantly undermining NATO uh
and constantly you know attacking all
the the European Union and you know
cheering on the UK for brexiting away
from the EU I think that being said um I
think that bid has done a phenomenal job
uh when it comes to foreign policy I
think that the Coalition building was so
important for Ukraine Russia and I'm so
happy that he decided to go to our
European allies and our NATO allies and
try to build a coalition of people to
help Ukraine so that that wasn't only
the United States um personally
especially after doing a whole bunch of
research I do tend to side with Israel
Over um Palestine in a lot of the
Israeli Palestinian conflicts I'm glad
that Biden while remaining a staunch
defender of Israel is trying to re in
some of the more aggressive posturing
towards uh the Palestinians in the Gaza
Strip I'm I'm proud that Biden said Hey
listen we are going to delay some of
these attacks Hey listen we are going to
allow humanitarian Aid here Hey listen
we are going to try to uh you know not
kill as many Palestinian people down
there while still you know signaling
that he would be a sta supporter of um
of Israel in in the conflict assuming
the civilian casualties don't go too
high um for foreign policy I mean
blemishes I mean like the the biggest
one you can give to Biden is Afghanistan
and the pull out there but man are we
going to talk about you know the uh
Inspector General report that says that
one of the biggest reasons why the
Afghanistan pullet was so disastrous was
because of the Doha Accords where Donald
Trump headed talks that didn't even
include the Afghanistan army uh I mean
like these were disasters like when when
Biden took office we had 2500 troops
left in Afghanistan like what was the
options even uh afforded to Biden at
that point um obviously you've got the
abandonment of the Kurds in Northern
Syria you know for the Turkish armies to
lay waste to um you talk about Iran and
North Korea although I'm not sure where
uh Ben would land on
those